in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Ilya
and Julia hi guys how are you good great
welcome welcome
where do you all live Raleigh North
Carolina all right welcome to Nashville
thank you thanks for coming to hang out
with us so you're here to do a debt-free
screen we are how much have you played
off we've paid off a total of a hundred
and twenty thousand dollars and that was
with a sale of a house and a large chunk
of I came from sale of a car so cash
flowed a total of about sixty thousand
dollars okay one hundred and twenty but
sixty was from selling thing yes all
right and how long did this take took
about 14 months okay cool
making what kind of range of income
during that time well we started out
separately before we got married and so
we were making 60 and 40 so 100 total
and then whenever we got married we
combined everything and now by the time
we paid everything off we make now 120
thousand nice raises very good 20% raise
in 12 months no slack lots of overtime
what do you guys do for a living I'm a
special ed teacher mhm and I am a
project manager for an air emissions
testing company oh very cool good for
you guys so you got married 14 months
ago or July over the summer started
working on this parts before and then
eight months later after being married
finish it up yeah all right very cool so
tell me the story how did this all
happen
we began before we got married and I
read your book my parents gave it to me
mm-hmm probably five six years ago I was
maybe 21 and I opened it up and I read
the whole thing and I thought well this
guy doesn't know what he's talking about
I see how others live around me what I'm
not gonna do what he tells us to do and
I continued living the way I kept living
kept borrowing more and more money and
kept not never saying no to myself until
eventually just got in over my head and
I actually what what really prompted me
to begin your program is reading dr.
Stanley's book millionaire next door mmm
and I read it and all of a sudden
everything I read in your book years
prior licked and I reread it again and
after that it was on
so when a book full of research about
how people become millionaires
and their habits lined up with what you
had heard me say before all of a sudden
maybe I was okay I got it it's a it's a
good way to do it I like it so how old
are you guys I'm 29 and he's right
around there
yeah close enough 29 and right around
there so how did this conversation take
place that you guys were going to work
on this together before and after
marriage how did this who's idea tell me
how the story unfolded well Ilya had
said you know that he had read your book
previously and so he introduced me to
you okay and shared the book with me and
so I read it and agreed to get on board
I had already like had a budget and was
doing some things but wasn't really
doing everything I needed to do yeah
there's some fine-tuning
exactly okay and gave you common
language to work on it in your in your
engagement period during pre marriage
counseling and all that and and Julia
was really my rock throughout this
process even though I started the
program and I was the one that was
really gung-ho and excited about it I am
a weird combination of nerd and free
spirit yes very hard to control your
money when you're that way yeah I got
you okay very cool so what's the house
that sold whose it was my condo we both
owned properties separately and so when
we got engaged I moved in with him and
we sold my condo I got you what did your
condo sell form was around 50 okay all
right and that took care of that and
then and you sold a copic car well there
was a little car just really expensive
Oh an expensive car and what was it it
was a 2008 BMW m3 Oh
oh yeah eight liter v8 Oh a naturally
aspirated they don't make them like that
anymore I'm thinking this resilience car
yeah it was yeah well it's good for him
to get rid of the other woman before you
get married right
he was in love I could tell the good
news is is that you married a real man
because he put his family and his wife
above stuff and you can get stuff later
and you're gonna have nice things you
just can't have nice things having you
and you guys made that kind of a
decision ahead of time that's pretty
cool yeah this speaks volumes about your
character they really does and they
don't let us fool you we had to
sacrifice really deep and in fact I kept
a list of everything that I had the
sacrifice when we started this journey
and I actually brought it here with
Santa Claus Christmas list here and it's
about that long it really is yeah now we
have the opportunity to have all these
things but honestly they don't mean as
much anymore yeah it just it changes
it's weird when you can afford them you
don't want them as much because you know
what they're really cost buy them right
and that's that throws you a curve on
buying things so well very cool you guys
very cool so what do you tell people the
secret there's a young couple out there
thinking about getting married right now
they got a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars in debt they're you 18 months
ago what do you tell them the secret to
getting out of debt is you know he and I
actually talked about this this morning
and you know it's not really any secrets
you talk about them all the time and so
what worked really well for us is of
course the budget communicating with
each other we have you know monthly or
bimonthly meetings of course we use the
envelope system for groceries and pet
and car and that sort of thing and that
works really well for me especially
because I maintain that part but yeah
I'm in a budget of course we're about
from your perspective Elia so for me
well I'd say the hardest part and the
most important part was to really be
committed you have to go all in you
can't just attempt to do it and having a
budget was something that I always knew
I had to do but I was never able to do
it I'd start at once I started again I'd
go a month and I'm like oh man look at
how much money I'm spending on this and
I just stopped doing it because I'd
rather not look at the numbers yeah and
all of a sudden when you make that
commitment it you just don't give up you
have to keep going that's what it's all
about that's how it changes things and
that's why so few people can really pull
it off and that's why it is so inspiring
have you on the air today
congratulations y'all honor to have you
stop by and to do your debt-free scream
your story is inspiring you are a
rockstar young couple you are going
places big and beautiful very proud of
you yeah and Julia Raleigh North
Carolina a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars paid off including sixty
thousand dollars worth of things sold
fourteen months it took them making 100
up to now 120 count it down let's hear a
debt free scream 3
I love it congratulations you guys very
very very well done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head
and make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind